bola solta divisão mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um carro usando
uma caneta 3d já é normal de trazer este
vídeo pro canal porque eu gosto bastante
e agora também agir basten patrocinado
alguns vídeos com esta caneta 3d o que é
muito bom é ivan este vídeo é
patrocinado pelo dia 10 porque é uma
lógica que caso vocês não conheçam que
nunca difícil né mãe conhecida é a venda
de canetas três de vários tipos de
canetas não é mais barata você encontrou
mais barata se vocês forem lá ver no
site que vou deixar link de inscrição é
encontrando em telemóveis tablets
quadricóptero já aviões e helicópteros
além de ter comandado a fazer as coisas
telecomandados que eu gosto bastante
disse o que quer comprar pois alterar ou
seja usaram que os motores os temas os
servos pra fazer coisas de frente por
exemplo de moto carro faça algumas peças
com esta caneta 3d
o então como impressora 3d é outra coisa
é que eu quero muito ter que a emissora
transmite por fase estou automaticamente
ou seja não tem que ser eu a fazer a mão
no computador foi a peça que quer fazer
ea máquina faz passado e marinha ou sei
lá tenta também da peça então aquilo é
mesmo superfície depois fazer os
próprios jogou-os armas de frente e
capacetes e ainda fazer muita coisa
mesmo com isso é mais para os veres
depois né só tô aqui imaginar umas
coisas aí eu estou fazendo agora a
cadeira que usa e popular um para fazer
o molde e depois coloquei o filamento
por cima
caso vocês não tenham uma caneta e 3d e
quero fazer também podem fazer mas em
vez de usar o filamento 3d podem usar a
popular vai fazer especialmente popular
um colo usando cola e depois é só fazer
um circuito elétrico como vou mostrar
mais para frente eles que fazer um gol
aí elas por ser no final deste vídeo
só que este meu ver bastantes coisas
quer us 500 mil inscritos então eu vou
dizer o que vou aí para quando chegar lá
e além de caneta e vou sortear mais
algumas coisas que ainda não saiu mas
ainda tem tempo esse vídeo vai ser daqui
duas semanas exatamente daqui duas
semanas e fazer um vídeo é explicar o
que vocês têm que fazer para se
habilitarem
é um dos prêmios aqui e desta vez não
vai ter concurso como da última vez em
que vocês tenham fazer um vídeo de um
projeto é só tem que chegar lá carga no
link de inscrição e conseguir nas redes
sociais é e pronto já estamos habilitar
a ganhar um dos prêmios e agora
recentemente fiz o instagram só agora é
só isso não só que as redes sociais não
vou montar redes sociais porque eu não
tenho muito tempo mas agora como escolas
tamanha a cavar e vêm as férias e tal
então eu decidi fazer um integrante e
tem custado vídeo vídeo vídeo não tem
custado fotografia quase todos os dias
então se vocês não quiserem lá seguir
vou deixar aqui o link na descrição do
facebook e do instagram no facebook o
posto mais coisas sobre o canal no
instagram é mais sobre as coisas que eu
faço até uma foto do ídolo que eu fiz
não sei agora que foi bem bacana e
depois vou postar vídeo é mostrar como é
que eu fiz greve que eu vou pro ainda
não sabe como estão as imagens porque
ainda não tirei do cartão de memória é
mais um princípio elementar busnello
tentar marciano um músico eu comecei lá
nos sets
mas quanto pelo professor de pré
visualização tava bom para vocês
entenderem como faixa foi só pena que eu
só dou umas oito horas quando eu fui ver
num horas depois quando eu tinha voltado
à tarde é casa mas foi divertido fazer
já era o segundo que eu fiz mas desta
vez foi mais fácil porque nevo era mais
compacto e vamos rota para cortar aquilo
como se fosse uma bandeira
por lá os boxes frontal fire foi mais
fácil do que da primeira vez que ela
estava mole e então a gente tinha que
batera né
fui fazer também não aborda o time de
tite no último vídeo é e fui e fiz muito
bem
quer dizer muito vai muito bem foi
dinheiro tá da pista sem a ajuda de um
instrutor que na verdade é muito
aconselhável porque vocês caem bastante
no primeiro dia e há legendas mas vocês
não sentem no dia a seguir quando vão
acordar eo chico brito em alguns
músculos
o corpo que nem sequer imaginava que
existiam porque os de um bastante ok
então é melhor coisa a fazer em logo no
primeiro dia pedirem um instrutor e foi
o que eu fiz no dia a seguir por um
instrutor e um deus falava inglês então
tive que entender tudo pelo gesto inútil
trazia um caminho é e com isso conseguir
safar um bairro ensinou-me e no segundo
dia já conseguia tirar pista toda sem
cair de cima a baixo então foi muito
feliz mesmo e obter foi destaque no
primeiro dia e evitar algumas quedas
porque fiz um 360 mesmo tempo mesmo 360
não é o tipo do lado e mesmo assim foi
muito bacana e o plano vivo ainda só é
mas foi bem bacana mas a razão principal
pela qual eu fui lá foi mais por visitar
o meu tio que eu sou houve uma vez que
eu ia família deu e foi aqui essas sete
anos atrás e eu estava vindo a anunciar
mais ou menos 3 14 anos exatamente
instalar a 3 14 anos e fui lá e gostei
bastante de ver um modo de vida de
frente às casas estão de frente just
ouvida a comida é bem é tudo diferente
porque é na outra ponta assim do mundo
por assim dizer e as pessoas têm outras
condições climáticas têm que ser um
outro tio do vila foi uma experiência
diferente e eu quero voltar mas quer ir
visitar a capital porque não foi à
capital fui a uma cidade não vai lá mais
para o interior das florestas e estudo
foi possível graças ao então muito
obrigado mesmo que eu tenho família mas
da família a mãe que dispersa por todo
lado então é sempre bom vê lo e agora
estou a fazer a reserva de vídeos
combustível falar também no último vídeo
aí já fiz uma lista de muitos projectos
que eu quero fazer
caso você não tenha visto um vídeo
estava 100 vídeos porque eu vou para a
universidade para o ano e quero ter
muitos vídeos apresentados para ser um
estudante normal aqui pra não ter tipo a
não fazer as coisas à pressa e quer
mesmo
quero fazer as coisas acontecer a
colaborar em grupos fazer jogos com
outras pessoas é ter uma vida normal é
isso basicamente que eu preferia deixar
o youtube começar logo a trabalhar isso
mas eu quero passar por essa parte da
vida de estudante saber como é ser um
estudante universitário porque temos
fazer as coisas certas no momento certo
josh é isso é uma coisa que eu fizer a
lista de projetos e muitas pessoas e fiz
essa lista lendo os vossos comentários e
vi com muita gente tem que dar o nosso
papel mas a questão é eu já fiz muitas
armas de papel e vocês querem que
continue a fazer armas papel do mesmo
gênero com o mesmo organismo demais com
outro formato é esse pessoal diga nos
comentários
vocês querem que eu continue a fazer a
um papel com o mesmo se temos mesmo os
gatilhos mães com outro formato mais
realista ou com outro filme duras
o tamanho é porque eu posso fazer por
causar mas com elásticos que usar folhas
a4 e desta vez usar folhas a 3 e fazer
melhor e adaptar por mais elásticos e
coisas do gênero
aí e só gostaria de saber a vossa
opinião ou se tiverem outras idéias do
projeto da china os comentários agora
porque estou fazer a lista e estou a
trabalhar para realizar agora muitos
vídeos e depois ter assim não tenho
problema já vai na universidade que
estou bastante entusiasmado da escola
não gosta da escola mas estudar é uma
coisa que eu gosto bastante e eu
tenciono fazer isso o mais tempo
possível estudar e o continue a estudar
é porque eu gosto de coisas novas uma
coisa
para quem se prepara na parte da conexão
e do poliduto é e é isso
como eu disse ok vocês não tiverem uma
caneta 3d podem fazer estudo usando
população em vídeo e esta parte plástica
da caneta 3d e veja aqui como funciona é
só vocês por ele e bateria a primeiro
tempo por lá também quer estimular os
pequenos dos pulseiras que já usei
algumas armas cunha parte é no conector
à lusa sem nem por que não tenha
introdutor o introdutor a menos só para
ligar o motor e já está a funcionar
isto é muito rápido e eu a produção está
em cima da mesa porque essas duas
pessoas uma para pagar o carro e outro
para ganhar e vejam que a evolução que
eu fui fazendo até chegar ao último deu
a descrição da minha vida mudou bastante
é e muito obrigado
bem tudo bom até a próxima
é bastante simples mas era só pra vocês
aí que está o circuito